oh yes I remember when I first met
you're like oh somebody in tech that
like sports I was like so like well
that's what I like the best
so ESPN 8 like kind of like Sports
Illustrated and like the local news in
sports and then I really think bleacher
report disrupted ESPN and now if you
look I really think barstools is
disrupting bleacher report and I think
it's happening because of podcast so it
to me what's interesting about
publishing is like when the mediums
change what are the white spaces so a
lot of what I'm thinking about with the
gallery and pure Lau being the first
play a member it is so I've actually
there's another thing which is like I
love nostalgia so like I actually want
when I bump here while I was like I'm
gonna find and then reframe it as if it
was built in 2020 so like I think for me
what I really want to accomplish in this
hour is I want to reverse so unlike 99
percent like if you look at every person
that I can how many people here actually
knew what Y Combinator was the first
year 2 or 3 clip correct I think I are
more likely I'm capable of creating the
offers and the partnership than any of
my contemporaries because I think an
independent I'm I'm more grounded in it
and I just have more hard for it to me
that's like to me it's really as basic
as that I just I genuinely believe that
you guys are a very important pillar of
culture it's probably the way I would
put it and I you know I have a lot of
confidence because much like social
anything that I get deeper into
inherently the agency gets better at
because I can create the strategy and so
as I'm doing my thing and not only doing
my but just kind of like digging deeper
into the content things of that nature
so I want to I want to first kind of
hear like what are the wants or needs or
dreams that people were doing or or what
kind of partnerships do you want because
maybe you're still early and you're
hacking it too so like maybe you don't
even know exactly how you want it
um but that's I'd like to listen for a
few minutes of like the State of the
Union or the launch dreams or hopes two
years ago Steven I can't actor in a bull
yep
imagine for the seven years we were gone
nothing chanting maybe the only thing
that changed was the sight doubled every
year in traffic but the product didn't
change the business didn't change like
frozen and on and any other conditions
died but thankfully he kept growing and
so when we came back down two years ago
we found something that basically wasn't
coming back to old house or like coming
at your childhood room for nothing's
chance
yeah except now it's way more popular
than Fletcher but the last two years
have been like hitting reset and now
finally building or shipment we've built
seven years go free at last upon hustler
mommy cray me with the words she always
told me I was perfect son go get what
you deserve there's winners and there's
losers stay apart to form a gang bye go
to another zone and [ __ ] opinions
sellers things out see ain't nobody
getting a hand you know hell and ain't
no cosines and ylabel mom I did it
myself
ain't no complaints oh my sodding no
excuse a curb Lane I cut the grass
computed snakes but you're not read on
the second lecture you guys don't know
each other
alexis is the co-founder of reddit okay
david levy is the president of turner
and alexis is a huge Redskins fan yeah
Marv I like that one sorry furniture to
return so I was I could have tackled in
three years now
vally me right they usually piggy
devotion turn yeah we Magic Man magic
help me remember all those shitty use
but no that's exactly why you're a fan
it pays off hold on hold on lady for how
old are you right so what you're did
Favre take over 90 91 93 94 93 right so
what's that that's yeah that's where I'm
going
this is 2040 years right a good run you
guys will be good for 24 years you've
been in the mix I'm a no hump okay stop
stop oh yeah they still say I changed of
course my hand I bet it's spinach at a
brain rearrange and notice of the
centuries a man they told you the gun
the one that swing is worse likes fine
so I'm still got say enough I never stop
unless you say so I'm not the one to a
list producer tail marry money amply
should snap on my Beach this entire like
ecosystem here is completely a b2b
environment this entire thing here like
agencies want to win an award because
they get more business brands want to
win an award because it gives them air
cover to do the things they want to do
and it completely has nothing to do like
normal human beings don't know this
exists like your friends that are your
neighbors don't realize this week is
happening this is not the Academy
[ __ ] award like so I think that yeah
I like you yeah yeah I mean it's a very
pretty place but I think I think that I
think there's two I'd love to hear it
his no I mean inherently advertising as
we've known it for the last 50 60 years
and why innovations so interesting and I
agree when I say dead the monetization
of breaking up content in a TV
environment to his point if we evolve
with the times Nintendo was a playing
card company that business might have
been dead they've evolved over the last
70 years into the company they are I
think anything that stops a human being
from doing what they actually want to do
is inherently a bad thing in a world
where technology is rapidly innovating
to allow people to have a better
experience I'll give you the best
I mean I literally couldn't have made
this up I get off the plane here I'm in
line in customs it takes two seconds we
all just did it and can write takes two
seconds but I'm in line two people
behind me and I hear because I'm
obsessed right now with voice Alexa
skills podcasting just voice as an
arbitrage to save time I think the
reason we're seeing the growth of these
things is it saves time literally the
two people non-english speaking but
speaking in English with accent so from
outside markets and just an interesting
conversation the lady says to the guy
she goes - wait a minute
do you know search is going to get
redefined with Alexa like give me an
answer she goes she goes you know how
are we going to get ads in here and he
goes yeah it's annoying
and I was laughing because I was like
said not one consumer in the world but
said these two ad tech executives thank
you how are you what success rate -
thank you thank you so much I get a
picture together definitely do it I love
it thank you so much all right if we go
tonight I don't know what else action
that picture you can get out you know I
never get out so I go I go I go
so now every education have to try to
show you money Hoover well I'm create
friend of mine so it's about spoken and
I wanna get us all some knowledge music
recite of course the shelf element gets
up I think you want to be sports there
you know I know yeah it's true I mean we
live it we live in a different level I
think walking in with Alexis reactor
like televisions we only eat like it's
like gloss over faces you guys are like
you don't even understand
it's not even you disagree you don't
even understand the words that are being
said yes Google commercial I'm hauling
all it top team in North America right
now already probably doing your thang
it's probably you member I'm ready for
more degree somebody all right yeah the
fact you're smart enough to follow ball
one means you already know but as much
hustle as you're deploying [ __ ] down
on that [ __ ] harder
Oh harder damn because I'm the one
nobody like me no one's like me that fax
I'm all driver change the standard every
time that I just I want
I worked upon the quantities of in my
life so uh I've worked a kind of other
things up there my life so awesome
Alberta funny things of your my life so
uh I work for President of Programming
so I have the mic but when I'm an
executive all I do is listen I'm revert
I'm trying to reverse engineering fix I
feel like I'm in a sexy business like
what's the issue and I'm the last line
of defense I mean you gotta get you got
to get the other people to rise cause
you can't because you're not doing the
best way to get people to rise to have
them hurt out of a level this way to
have great leaders like great management
is to give a [ __ ] about them which then
forces and suffocates them to give a
[ __ ] underneath these laws like me as RC
creative okay like they'll tell you I
put a lot of pressure on it you better
be managing underneath me the way I
manage you because when I hear like
everyone's stressed into something I
don't do that to me but any I don't P&L
any of you so why the hell are you doing
like if you're manifesting your own
thing I'm like I'm empathetic to that is
a human freak let's talk that through so
like I'm just in the business of having
a 15 minute meeting when I get back
where it's like Karen is complaining
that Suzy ruining our I'm incident I
like it and I don't like it because I'm
a Yenta I like it because of how you fix
the company it's a ghost it's how you
build a good company well your company
is people right I mean and even and I
think every comment IP yes but it's my
company's people in the cliche agency
world every company is wrong I think you
guys are sitting on gold because
business and entrepreneurship stood as
truth American Pie and and what I love
is watching you guys as media companies
Trump each other always based on who's
right so who's right Pablo was right to
do that
snapchat feels like one of you Inc
entrepreneur for whoever Yahoo disease
Forbes or somebody's going to make the
best podcast and win and so more
magazines because that's going to happen
one of you is going to make the best
Alexis skill that's going to own the
morning brief and you're going to win
somebody is going to create the video
blog like you guys should make the news
like woes that show that Sorkin row Cora
or miserable yeah you guys should
literally do what I do if you like made
a Fast Company if you guys share right
if you guys finish up it's not a joke if
you guys did a vlog of your office every
day in a year you would be 20 to 50
percent up on all web new things that
matter if you guys literally did the
office meets me room meet Stacy flan
every day on Facebook basket you know
like your shop and you're me exactly
producers so it's not like anything gets
out that you don't want out it's
powerful redefining the media I
basically built this company on giving
stuff away I'm a big thing you've always
think like you don't get your about like
talkback a gateway into this is nice I
think you can slide to as many five
climbers or next you didn't write some
stuff thanks I gotta leave right biggest
joke on planet
our life and we're in the right place
doing everything right I don't know
we're going to win a little bit
somebody sent I hope Charlie meant to
explain programmatic advertising to
people who are being the most delicious
I read a book everybody has the romance
point it's back I'm always trying to
suffocate our romance people
conversation we had yesterday
what's that Mendoza you know that's more
like [ __ ] people make these moves
before a million dollars in sauces like
a billion dollars in sales
quiet
it was so productive morning was moving
it a Vocaloid client big breakfast
well it's super well going to the panel
obviously that with us with a david levy
on bobby s from company i was super fun
now heading and talking from the uh
native all right that's a great most
thing on yeah it was kind of being but
it's not normal so you get that fancy
but um she's having a headquarters to
have meeting something and we think
about it so I'm excited about that
we do super well so far very good up to
24 hours to be get some business done
moolah small businesses are becaus right
you come here for a week between these
couple months I'm going to see 15 to 25
cm ever CEOs that I wouldn't have seen
otherwise for definitely an advantage
gentlemen that's what I focus money like
far as a hey hey soldier till we may yes
I remember yeah yeah so um so are you
actually like them
boxing yeah so and I mean - nope
tomorrow actually so so the canal
company like I would love that
that would be amazing I am massively
impressed and like curious how you guys
thinking about that little well thanks
for asking about those okay I'm sorry I
get this get this if you're on that
we're hearing this is celerity on the
street thinking so most humbly didn't
this is a celerity this is n layer 30
you've been voted number one most
overrated CEO but also in this fun event
number one best-looking see ya
how do you feel about those two assassin
acai giving her the first one anything
what are you doing I'm not on me
oh yeah oh my god I'm going to snap oh I
meet you how are you thank you very
thank you so much what you say thank you
so much yeah I'm up here in cancer art
until Friday
oh wow they refer to me nice to meet you
thanks for saying hello hi hi okay look
I love your top section please do what
makes me happy and I want to do for you
be a nice little gift you're welcome
don't get crazy you don't go look at the
top
I'll go right to the market - I remember
my ankle which yesterday I've hurt my
ankle
commit a lot of salespeople editing and
natural marketing DNA and vice versa and
if you notice the people that are
successful if you stripe away their
ability to be political within an
organization they're the marketing
person that the salespeople respect or
the salesperson marketing people respect
I think those are people that actually
have what I had but I don't think I'm
some unicorn yeah I think there's a lot
of people who actually have the ability
to be good at sales and marketing I
think companies who are she to go one
route or the other and then thus we
don't even realize that capability so in
entrepreneurial and we see it we see it
less than organization I could see
nobody I create content and consume my
audience response to it and stay in my
vortex and I like database and hack and
I think I'm actually scared to consume
others because I think it's a leak and
so I just stay my little cocoon you got
it of course reasoning that what while I
think they are what makes you think is
twenty five minutes or maybe beyond what
is your important that how to say five
minutes become an engaging or because
it's one numbers when you come to
digital you can track numbers pretty
much who drop down when in one minute
but I know what's amazing about
creatives from my perspective as an
entrepreneur is somebody took one but
when vine was getting going right I I'd
broken out as a YouTube star so when I
saw buying I'm like oh [ __ ] here it is
again I went hardcore I like signed her
own yarn
cameron dallas and nash grier like i
knew all of them like i find them I was
like I don't know what I'm gonna do with
them but there's something here but you
know what I learned through that phase
that excited me is that if you make a
shitty six second vine people are gone
in two seconds and I think if star wars
announced tomorrow that they're making a
five hour 18 minute episode eight
the world would cheer like if you make
great product people will consume
but when you think they're not switched
to an ethnic damp Facebook that kind of
language is sure I mean look I mean I
look I think so one thing I think people
are good at is understanding format
changes so Facebook has technology right
now that allows you to go from feed
right to the screen like right now in 24
months the majority view will take your
phone see something and literally
licking to hear
so you're thinking in the way the world
is right now
so you're thinking longer form higher
quality makes more sense in the next
environment than it does in a Facebook
environment I know that everybody is
going to be agnostic and on big screen
right so got it so to me what you're
doing is you're taking this moment and
you're deploying where do we see higher
quality things that nature which is
ironic in itself because if you weren't
the Hollywood 40 years ago they were
[ __ ] on Netflix right you know so
like it's very fast by the way HBO I
mean the one thing that I recommend to
all youngsters is do history right like
all these things like HBO was lowbrow
quality content right like it's amazing
to watch it all you need is that
execution so to me the one great thing
about creatives is is it is the
punchline of the whole thing I just I
just want to support mediums that give
it more expression and I'm a businessman
so I understand the 30-second spot in
the 15-second spot and to discuss to
have around programmatic I understand
why it's happening it's the economics of
scale to run businesses but it doesn't
take away the fact that those are not
the best experiences for the customer
and what technology does is suffocate
out what's funny I'm see drug with
deliver except should everything work
and I'm all precision bad decisions
taught the language I'm talking I'm
talking bite knives but enables who said
I never duress it's like to do that
they've all seen because they once left
me already people without demeaning
there you thank you technically another
sit-down with get receipt put in the
[ __ ] aside is that you found your
name so bra nice if no matter sighs yeah
I'm going to put that this is I'm always
I don't know if you guys know this idea
of vlog every day and even Facebook so
some of this will be on heat and then
sometimes we'll take the whole thing and
put as a separate piece probably to the
especially instead of not like when
you're correct I can make into the
outcome for me and like I said this year
I do it that a lot of high school yes
because like when I was correct like
even if the what I'm doing wrong is like
side of my teachers or my playfellow yes
like I always stuck to it and actors and
disease really stayed on because like I
got graduated on the honor roll around
seven it was really awesome and I was
really inspired about what you said and
I decided to that yeah you're welcome
stick to that yeah for short thank you
thank you
[Music]
be historically correct thank you hi
thank you
bye guys I'm gonna go bye bye bye bye
daddy so I love you and I school before
you sugar-coated a because that don't
help us train they want success that
they want sympathy
it's just how it seems I think the
bigger question is what you can't take
an idea public you have to put an idea
into something that is taken yet that
you're like I don't know how to I like
to get people to the water you have to
put it in this container
what's the container that you put that
energy to I've done it in a personal
brand I've done it in an agency I've
given my passions and points of view
suck it you can do that by putting on
when I decide to build a business next
the product it's going to be huge
because I'm going to get to prime my
career and I'm going to execute it take
me to figure out how how and what you
want to execute it again if you want to
be a thought leader do you want to be
you want it to be a book you want it to
be an agency I wanted what I was eating
30 years or negative they wouldn't
unless you get them to meet it or you so
they wouldn't and you would end up like
all the other books or you can start the
process of you know I mean you know who
I am
I've shown you the blueprint you can
start producing confident scale and over
the next year and a half
build enough of a base that gives you a
chance to a lot of people to read it
in the day to days I think you don't
because it becomes your norm yeah it's
like citizens in in uh in communist
countries they know but they don't know
like the thing that people don't realize
it was fifteen-year-old girls ask every
fifteen-year-old girl in the world
country agnostic who the five most
famous people are to them when they name
three people that are on Instagram and
snapchat only and YouTube for three
because they'll Rihanna and I get it but
like I don't think people understand
that's what's going to happen in the
advertising industry this festival this
festival in 2023 is going to be
rewarding Facebook videos not commercial
and you don't by the way like from a
pure creative sense they're looking so
much better you know much better a
three-minute 18 second video that
inspires you feels to a 30-second spot
what commercial has really gotten you
it's hard I rather not smile fake I
rather keep it on Gabrielle flick the
switch and hit the dice and see who
shines with a chef it is the reason that
I'm here before mule eggs were saying
ìlook mistakes right in your face and
said I'm show me my place and you should
try to track me down and see the places
I'm going and every blog on the tool
should get the soundtrack from running
with
I work upon upon observe in my life so
uh I've worked a part of my life so uh I
just took the Holden young creative I
was like well if you want on a simple
career on snapchat no chance yeah
classic advice right okay my ads are off
the morning yeah I know it looked great
love it let me know how I can help I'm
doing a speech sound Oh see you tomorrow
yeah after your uh I'm good
oh yeah now my coffee up that well then
be nice and spend some time it had a
very clear feeling I just looked at that
tiny advertising Association I swear to
God I literally literally just in my
head said I'm going to dominate that
[ __ ] country in three years like over
the next three years that is such a
weird feeling that was
I love that bucket feeling that's one I
know good shits about to happen and you
have that I don't want to make it up I
don't I don't know guys but like one
thing like like it happens like covers
of like magazine the TV stuff like like
you know like I basically thought that I
would be on the shark tank or voice of
apps like flat-out run on that like how
long ago three years ago like flat-out
like what I want to smell by one of what
the can hear like the child hasn't
allowed a little literally looked at in
[Music]
my life so I I'd like to find a fun of
things up there my life
I work to find a fine
all night so uh how much the final
finalist
hi tiger oh yeah good you have your own
microphone thank you hello it's going to
be a meta thing continue home management
okay I think the most like a couple of
minutes yet up I've got started wishing
a new idea was about two years like I
feel that you probably be compromise
whenever you grown-up law at time but I
still water is just black men muscle
isn't media thank you I mean that
genuinely thank you it's very sweet
I just think it was very kind of
straight to the point
no be a yeah and it just resonated
really and yes like just tell you that I
appreciate them and the love means a lot
to me it's a feedback loop Nick you know
feeds it right
how am I getting my middle and then feel
more empowered I want to sell oxygen
that's always been my dream
this is the modern decision programming
a little boxes doing live a traditional
media companies got 44 bands out there
trying to do the same thing this is new
vs. cool in a ridiculous setting and a
lot of emotion money a propaganda see
[Music]
yes what about against you yes I can't
argue with yesterday's get your talent
you're good you're good I'm good okay
dude forever love to see you again you
will I'm great alright very good well
good thing now if you guys how are
deeply entrenched in like how you came
out really good
but winners about it's just so obvious
like it's literally binary you've had
competitors I know both of your
competitors very well last time you some
of them want to hold on to the way it
was it were first you know yeah and then
they're just romantic what are you first
it's only who's best and then it's who's
romantic and who's not today extreme
you're happening otherwise good star
true it's like it's like I don't use
first I listen if people get to their
finish line they sell they get what they
want if they want to set up the family
don't know that's life but in business
correct that's different but in the game
of business like you just build and
iterate that's what I spend your time
today so it's like you're what expected
I'm spending all my time building the
Machine of vaynermedia upon hustler mama
creamy with your words she always told
me I was perfect son go get what you
deserve it's when as in as losers stay a
partner former gang but your tongue for
not as Arlen [ __ ] opinion selling stands
up
see ain't nobody gonna hang you know
help and ain't no coat on the label mom
I did it myself
ain't no complaints on my side ain't no
excuse I could life I cut the grass
debuted snakes but yet I treat on the
same remaining humble case I stumble
yeah they still care I changed of course
my hand I let it spin it today praying
rearrange and notice of the century a
man they told you the gun the one that
swing is words like spine so until God
say enough I never stop unless you say
so I'm not the ones who a lace producers
hell marry my dear please and snap on my
Beast
because I'm the one nobody like me no
one's like me that sex among driver
change your standard every time that I
I'll work yeah I think I can get a hug
you know you can't even respect you
can't even come and give me a handshake
just a handshake just again shake
that's good
[Music]
holy okay all right
only if you're all right archive
announced after Henley sleep I'm going
to find a fun adventure in my life
Alberta condom on essence of your mother
so I was to find a finer things up there
my life so funny I didn't interview the
other day and somebody asked me who a
business magazine asked me up who who
was an entrepreneur that I thought was
doing a good job or I looked up to or
who had it figured out and without any
hesitation this beautiful smart wildly
dressed woman to the right of me was the
easy answer for me I am I am one who
loves entrepreneurship
it's obviously as you can imagine been
so good to me and and I spend a lot of
time auditing everybody but especially
entrepreneurs how they navigate what
they do and I'm just so impressed and
watching Rachel navigate Micmac Bruce
and I see a lot of you already shaking
your head from sheer will hustle grind
like I think entrepreneurship is
firefighting
it's boxing it's like who can take a
good punch right like how do you
navigate through those days and so I'm
just very honored to co-host this
especially with so many people I admire
in the entrepreneur land and in the
corporate land and so I'm just very
thankful that you guys are here I hope
you enjoy and I'm really glad to be
there for you when you got the set and
off to the media wing party Michael
Caston the kind of like big event
networking event here a can got a
30-minute ride could answer your tweet
what an amazing entrepreneur rachel is I
put on my Instagram story you should
follow her sit down with Jerry be
putting the [ __ ] aside
he said you found your name so Brian is
just a matters up don't ever
sugar-coated a because that don't help
you in stream they want success or they
want sympathy
it's just how it seems I rather not
smile fake I rather keep it on Gabrielle
flip the switches hit the licensee who
shines with a chef he is the reason that
I'm there this formula was safe I look
mistakes right in their face and said
I'm show me my place